24 7. ah
[Music]
24 7. let's talk about this Google pixel
watch so the first generation of any uh
new piece of tech is always interesting
you know this is Google's first pixel
Smart Watch we have the Google pixel
phones and the pixel Buds and the pixel
tablet coming later that could be fun
too but yeah this is their first crack
at a pixel Smart Watch so I know I'm not
the only one who was very curious just
waiting for this thing to see what it
would look like what features they would
include how well it would work together
what the design would be and I also know
that I'm not the only one who's
disappointed in a lot of this stuff
let's talk about it so when you first
buy a pixel watch for 350 you get a
small 41 millimeter circular smart watch
it comes in this one size but there's
three colors black silver or gold the
black being the best in my opinion
because it is matte black while the
other two are very much glossy and the
front glass curves way over into a dome
shape made of Gorilla Glass 5. it's like
a Sleek little Pebble well not a Pebble
Smartwatch but a literal Pebble a very
lightweight weight Pebble and there's
only two buttons the crown that rotates
and pushes in and then a button right
above it the crown I think is really
good it sticks out enough it's usable
everywhere it has haptics when you
scroll with it nice and clicky the
button above it not so much it's pretty
small doesn't have much travel it's
still clicky but because of the domed
glass it's pushed fairly far back kind
of close to your wrist luckily you don't
really use it that much and then
connecting the watch bands at the top
and bottom happens through this clever
little push and slide system it's clever
I say because it can connect bands in
this really seamless looking way without
any lugs or bulky connections and the
first party watch bands do a really good
job of looking like they just jut out of
the side of the watch which is pretty
cool you might not care about this at
all if you never change watch bands but
as somebody who changes watch bands
every single day to sleep in a different
band I just get used to this motion a
lot and so I find it good when it's good
and this is also something very
important to get right in the first
generation because you don't really want
to have to change it three years in
because that makes everyone's watch
bands that they just bought for the past
three years incompatible so they're
trying to keep this for a long time so
Hardware wise I think this thing is
actually pretty beautiful I love the
simple Circle you can easily dress it
down and keep it subtle or you can just
go sports band or fabric band it seems
to fit right into a lot of different
places it's stainless steel it's water
resistant up to 50 meters and the back
happens to be pretty simple too it's
just a heart rate sensor blood oxygen
sensor and the ECG and up front this is
a thousand nit OLED display with a
mostly black background through most of
the software so it just kind of feels
like a black disc floating on your wrist
it's nice the only thing I wish is that
it was bigger or if there was a larger
version so I don't even have that big of
a wrist but this thing is just it's
pretty small which some people will like
but I just wish I had a larger screen
this watch is a 41 millimeter watch but
that measurement is just of the actual
outside of the casing when you actually
get a look at this thing the bezels are
pretty substantial and so the screen is
down to about 29 millimeters across now
I don't actually hate these bezels I
think it's it's kind of like the notch
on a phone you know a lot of people who
don't actually use it can make a big
deal about it because if you just look
at them they look silly but the mostly
black background throughout the UI does
a good job of hiding them and you really
only see them when you're looking for
them or if you set a photo as a watch
face but I really think a bigger watch
would feel even more modern for the
computer on the wrist nerds like me and
it would also solve the number one
problem of this Hardware which is
battery life because the battery life is
trash it's bad it's it's just not good
at all so on stage Google said what did
they say up to 24 hours was their claim
which probably should have been the
first red flag because if you think
about it 24 hours is like 8 A.M one day
to 8 A.M the next day so one day and one
night
but that's the maximum it's up to 24
hours so the always-on display is off by
default out of the box I turned that on
and it's literally measuring your heart
rate every single second all day every
day every single second that's a lot of
heart rate measurements so just for
context the Apple watch for example is
checking periodically through the day
and every five seconds while you're
sleeping so now here I'm getting more
like 18 hours tops which is not quite
enough to go all day and then do a full
night of sleep tracking so if you wanted
to sleep tracking like me basically you
have to charge it twice a day every day
sometime in the morning when you wake up
and then again sometime in the afternoon
before you go to sleep or it's just
gonna die if the thing drains about 20
to 25 battery just during one night of
sleep tracking now measuring your heart
rate every single second to the second
is actually kind of sick like it's
pretty cool there is a complication they
showed it on stage two of just the watch
telling you every second updating what
your heart rate is like I've never seen
anything like it it's the most accurate
heart rate tracking I've ever tried in a
wearable it's great for tracking
workouts heart rate recovery you know
this this is the Fitbit prowess going to
work no doubt but the other smart
watches that are now years in you know
the Samsung Galaxy watch 5 and the Apple
Watch series 8. they've all realized by
this point that the way you save battery
is by pinging all these sensors less
often like the battery saver mode on the
new Apple watch literally is just
pinging heart rate and GPS less and
turning off things like the always on
display and the blood oxygen readings
that are going on all the time in the
background that's how you save battery
so the fact that this watch does it all
the time can be cool
but also can nuke your battery all the
time when I go to bedtime mode and just
turn on like the sleep mode it doesn't
say it's stopping those heart rate
measurements it continues to measure my
heart rate constantly I will say though
the Saving Grace that makes it usable is
that it does charge up very fast it does
come with this plastic Puck charger in
the box with a pretty weak magnet that
feels like it could easily fall off also
very first gen feeling but it could go
from like 10 to 40 percent in like 15
minutes which is amazing and it can go
from zero to a hundred in about an hour
but okay all that being said the most
clumsy thing about the pixel watch for
sure is the fact that it's also a Fitbit
or let me rephrase that
Fitbit isn't built into the watch so
much as it's like bolted on to the side
so wear OS 3.5 here is
it's fine it's pretty familiar it's
still intuitive you've got your watch
face with a swipe down to get to all
your customizable Quick Settings that's
nice and then you swipe up to get to
your notifications your list of apps is
one click of the crown away but your
recent apps is behind that secondary
button that I find I almost never use
then you can swipe sideways between a
predetermined set of tiles that you can
organize in the phone app and these are
like these big quick shortcuts to
screens that you might use a lot ongoing
background things will show up at the
bottom so if you have a notification
there's a little dot for your
notification dot if there's a music
playing it'll show a little animation
for that and if you're in the middle of
something like a workout and a new
notification comes in it'll show the
logo down there for that too so to
control any of the normal watch faces
and complications which I really like a
lot of them you go through the Watch app
makes perfect sense but then for the
fitness stuff that's where Fitbit which
Google acquired in 2019 comes into play
so when you set up the watch you
actually make a Fitbit account and it
starts you off with 6 free of Fitbit
premium which is a subscription service
so as a smart watch I've mostly enjoyed
using it's been fine like it's smooth it
has a good performance but it does feel
disjointed sometimes in ways where like
you'd expect it to sync more things with
the phone but it doesn't like for
example when I put my pixel phone my
pixel phone in Do Not Disturb mode the
watch does not go to do not disturb mode
it keeps buzzing it has its own separate
Do Not Disturb mode basic stuff like it
feels like it should work together more
than just being a Bluetooth accessory
connected to your phone but then you do
a bunch of Fitness stuff a bunch of
workouts or whatever sleep tracking and
then the watch dumps all of that Fitness
data into the Fitbit app now there is
still a Google Fit app by the way
the watch doesn't really talk to it at
all so what does that mean for the
future of the Google Fit app I don't
know your phone can still talk to it and
dump like step counting in there but
then you're using two different apps to
track Fitness so I I don't know and then
even throughout the watch UI all the
Fitbit stuff it's in there but it also
it kind of just feels like they just
dropped it in there on top like instead
of ECG it's Fitbit ECG and a set of
exercise it's Fitbit exercise and then
you start using these features and the
free six month trial before you realize
a ton of the stuff it's collecting and
that you're using like the breathing
rate heart rate variation sleep stage
tracking and sleep scores all of that
goes behind a Fitbit 10 a month
subscription paywall when the free trial
is over it feels like you can see the
Arc of the thinking where like Google
wanted people to use a Google watch so
they bought Fitbit and then as I
integrated it they realized oh people
love the Fitbit name and they still want
a Fitbit so you can't remove that name
or that branding so people now get the
Google watch that has Fitbit in it and
they use the Fitbit app but then there's
also Google fit in the background that
they hopefully also choose to use
sometimes
and they all don't really talk to each
other now all this stuff you know it
doesn't make the rest of the parts of
the watch worst use it all still works
it's just it adds to this first gen
feeling here where you can tell that
there is a lot that can get better and
this is the funny thing about reviewing
products that you're like hoping to be
good you end up sounding really harsh
like a disappointed parent or something
basically I think this whole pixel watch
thing has a lot of potential and I
really do enjoy parts of it having
Google assistant on my wrist everywhere
is awesome downloading music to stream
offline the turn-by-turn navigation with
maps The Voice to Text to respond to
Notifications all that is great but they
clearly still have some first gen
learnings to do like the the charger the
heart rate monitoring that is constant
that doesn't seem to have any adjusting
ability uh the Fitbit integration even
the connectivity problems I've had a
little bit of connectivity issues with
mine here and there but some of my
friends who are also reviewing this
watch right now have had a nightmare of
a time just keeping it connected to
their phone so I'll let them talk about
that in their reviews so like I was
hoping this would be some amazing watch
straight from the start which I should
know better right like first gen stuff
is never amazing right from the go but
you know it's starting from zero here
like there's not a lot of bands there's
not a lot of accessories for this it's
350 and for that money you could get a
more mature version of a smart watch
that has more features that has better
battery life that has things that aren't
behind a subscription paywall and that
ultimately will probably be a better
experience but for now
it's fine for their first foray into
forearm Fitness and fashion but
functionally it's still far from
finished
oh hey look a notification from this
video sponsor rocket money you might
heard of them they're previously known
as true bill that's when I signed up I
had this service for years but this is
an all-in-one Finance platform that
helps you keep track of your finances
and also helps you manage your money too
but actually my favorite feature of
Rocket money is that it helps you cancel
unwanted subscriptions which can kind of
just like pile up in the background so
you connect your bank account it scans
through all of your charges and then it
puts all in one place all of your
subscriptions and with like a single
press of a button will let you cancel
the stuff that you might have forgotten
about even if there's like a free trial
you signed up for a while ago you just
cancel it and be done with it but also
rocket money can help you lower your
monthly bills for your phone internet or
cable it says you literally take a
picture of your bill and the app will
negotiate the bills on your behalf it's
kind of sick and you can also monitor
your credit score right from the app
it's great it's easy to save money using
this thing so if you want to check it
out it's free or you can unlock more
features using the premium account just
go to rocketmoney.com MKBHD
it'll be a link right below the like
button if you want to head over and
check it out and I'll be over there too
but until the next one thanks for
watching
see you later
peace
[Music]